Let's see what else we've got here. Let's
go to our caller from the nine three seven
area code caller from nine three seven. What's
your name? Where are you calling from?
Is this me? Yes, it is.
Oh, my gosh. That's awesome. Hi, my name is
Austin. I'm from Flavor Town, Ohio.
All right. And Austin, please just keep the
phone a little further from your mouth because
you're coming in a little hot and it's crunching.
All right. Sorry about her.
Oh, my God, that's so much better. Thank you.
OK. So my question is. That.
So I'm kind of I've I've been talking with
my friends a lot about this, and I just wanted
to get your opinion on it. I am really concerned
about all of this malpractise that's gonna
be happening with the Postal Service. Yes.
And I'm worried about voting and voting in
by mail. So I feel like I have to vote in
person.
But I also am concerned about, you know, voting
in person because of coronavirus of.
Well, obvious reasons. Yeah, right.
So I guess, like.
Where should my priorities lie?
Well, OK. So he basically this is gonna be
a call that a lot of people have to make.
There are many people who rightly would would,
as I've said, crawl over broken glass to vote
in November. So you are going to have to make
the call.
Can you get as I've said before, they can
slow down the mail.
But right now it doesn't seem like they're
just going to throw absentee ballots in the
trash. So if you can get your ballot several
weeks before the election and mail it in,
even if they delay the ballots three, four
or five days, it's going to get there. And
by all reasonable estimates, it's going to
be counted. So that's number one, right. The
they're they're going to try. But if you can
get your absentee ballot in and send it in
early as I'm going to be doing here in Massachusetts,
you really shouldn't have a problem when it
comes to voting in person. Listen, the situations
are dramatically different in different precincts
where some places you put a mask on and you
go in and you're in and out in 10 minutes
and it's no big deal in other places. You
could be waiting for hours, surrounded by
people, mostly not wearing masks. And that's
a real concern. And it's going to be a very
individual decision. Unfortunately, there's
no there's no way I can tell you what makes
sense. But I I am confident that you should
be able to vote and have your vote counted.
I'm relatively certain that you will be able
to achieve that.
Makes sense. Yeah.
Yeah. Thanks, David. All right. Thank you.
Yes, a concern that many people have and is
going to be a very big deal going forward.